christine boutin vous avez 73 ans vous
êtes président d'honneur du parti
chrétien-démocrate vous avez participé à
votre dernière séance du conseil
départemental des yvelines
ce vendredi 20 octobre après avoir
occupé ce mandat depuis plus de 35 ans
alors pourquoi vous avez décidé de
démissionner tout d'abord je veux dire
est que la séance du conseil
départemental et hier c'était très beau
c'était très beau je voulais absolument
rien mais j'ai été très très touché par
l'authenticité des réactions de chacun
de mes collègues et je les en remercie
et je remercie pierre bédier pour cela
alors pourquoi je démissionnais tout
simplement parce que je tiens maison que
j'ai mes engagements en 2015 quand nous
nous sommes présentés avec georges bizet
je m'étais engagé auprès des électeurs
va démissionner au milieu de mon mandat
compte tenu de mon âge parce que j'ai
beaucoup hésité à me représenter
compte tenu de cet âge avait 70 ans et
qu' il y avait un risque front national
très important surtout quand on est donc
après en avoir discuté du reste avec
pierre bédier g qui m'a encouragé à me
représenter
j'ai décidé de partir mais en ayant
cette obligation de quitter au milieu du
mandat
donc je tiens mes engagements comme j'ai
essayé de le faire tout au long de ses
40 années de vie politique qui s'achève
effectivement le 31 octobre prochain
alors vous avez commencé votre carrière
professionnelle dans la communication et
la presse et vous débutez votre carrière
politique dans les yvelines lors des
élections municipales de 1977 à
auffargis pourquoi vous êtes lancé en
politique en 77 quand nous sommes
arrivés enfin nous sommes arrivés dans
les yvelines avec mon mari et mes
enfants 73 et en 77
il y avait les élections municipales et
moi j'avais dans le coeur depuis
toujours de servir de servir je sais ça
ce que j'avais envie et on peut servir
de mille manières mais
en étant élu local parce que j'avais une
tradition locale dans le berry d'élu
local dans ma famille je suis allé voir
le maire et je vais proposer ma
candidature est déjà en 1977
le fait d'avoir une femme sur une liste
était bien mais vous permettez de saluer
monsieur lévesque qui était le maire de
l'époque qui a été un personnage
déterminant dans ma carrière politique
puisque lui même à penser me voyant à
l'oeuvre à auffargis que je pouvais
devenir conseiller départemental ce qui
n'était absolument pas mon idée à
l'époque une fois que je suis devenu
conseiller municipal de farges ismer
d'auffargis naturellement j'ai plus vu
la réalité de ce territoire et je me
suis attaché
et comment ne pas s'attacher à ce sud
yvelines qui est un territoire
absolument magnifique
donc je me suis mise au service et
devenir conseiller général m'a permis
effectivement de prendre encore plus
conscience de cette réalité magnifique
vous avez d'abord été membre de l'udf si
vous avez créé votre propre parti
politique donc d'abord appelé le forum
des républicains sociaux devenus ensuite
le parti chrétien démocrate
comment vous définiriez vos convictions
politiques et le fondement idéologique
de ce mouvement
c'est le fondement idéologique
mon engagement politique et le respect
de la personne humaine de la conception
à la mort naturelle
voilà je pourrais rajouter comme une
cerise sur le gâteau et pardon pour le
fond ce qui est fait c'est que pour moi
tout homme même le pire des hommes même
le pire de mes adversaires et aimé de
dieu autant que je le suis je dois dire
que avec expérience
autant j'avais l'intuition dans le coeur
qui avait été blessé par cette loi sur
l'avortement alors que je mettais mes
enfants au monde
l'expérience de ses 40 ans ont montré
que si l'on touche aux plus petits
d'entre nous que nous avons tous été
c'est-à-dire l'embryon c'est l'humanité
tout entière qui est touché et qui est
fragile
quand on voit aujourd'hui
malheureusement le traitement qui est
réservé aux hommes à la personne humaine
et bien j'en ai fait qu être confortée
par rapport à cette analyse en qui vous
vous retrouver aujourd'hui au niveau de
l'engagement politique et de toutes ces
questions que vous évoquez la place de
l'homme dans la société
l'europe qui revient au devant de
l'actualité
quel est votre votre héritier ya pas
c'est pas ils sont pas nombreux ils sont
pas nombreux mais c'était ça fait partie
aussi du chalenge moi je crois beaucoup
je crois beaucoup en jean frédéric
poisson bien sûr qui a été battu de
façon scandaleuse
compte tenu de la qualité de la personne
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est la
démocratie et et c'est ainsi
jean-frédéric a une responsabilité très
importante sur les épaules pour porter
justement cette cette primauté de la
personne humaine il ya une personnalité
aussi à laquelle je vends rendent
hommage même si nous avons des nuances
et des nuances importantes même sur le
fond mais c'est gérard marché gérard
larcher a une expérience politique qui
ne peut que servir notre pays
voilà
il faudra
que ce soit affirmé de façon claire la
primauté de l'homme